this morning's shock inflation figures
meant kierstama only had one option
asking about the economy and he went big
on the blame game he knows very well the
cause of the mortgage catastrophe 13
years of economic failure and a Tory
kamikazu budget
economy and put mortgages through the
roof
the labor leader also seemed to have a
new three-word attack line
Willa Prime is to tell us how much the
Tory mortgage penalty Tory mortgage
penalty the Tory mortgage penalty is
going to cost the average homeowner I'm
told you'll hear a lot more of that in
the next 12 months zakiya also snuck in
a mention of Selby in Yorkshire location
of a key by-election next month and in
response really soon act strategy was to
argue economic challenges are evidence
internationally
perhaps the old gentleman could explain
why interest rates are at similar levels
in the United States in Canada in
Australia and New Zealand but in
contrast what do we hear from one more
gentlemen he wants to borrow an extra 28
billion pounds a year that would make
the situation worse he wants to ban new
supplies of energy from the naughty that
would make the situation worse now Kia
stalma's advisors say it was a
deliberate choice to focus on the issue
concerning voters the cost of living
crisis and Rising mortgage rates and not
deal with the soap opera of Boris
Johnson and the Privileges committee but
the labor leader still managed to slip
in the odd dig Mr Speaker I realized the
promise to spend all week saying he
doesn't want to influence anyone or
anything
in California but I'm talking about
movie told us here I'm sure from the
vantage point of his helicopter
everything might look fine
[Music]
it's not the lived experience of those
on the ground all that seemed to leave
the Prime Minister looking a little
irritable
no amount of personal attacks and Petty
Point scoring can disguise the fact that
the honorable gentleman does not have a
plan for this country Mr Speaker Now
personal attacks and Petty Point scoring
may not be the point of pmqs but they're
always a regular feature and as Kia
Stalin didn't major on Boris Johnson the
snp's Westminster leader as well as
laborback benchers filled that void
given the dire economic reality of
today's not no clear that he's taken as
honesty lessons from Boris Johnson does
the Prime Minister believe that the
reward for being a law breaker should be
to be made a lawmaker so just to recap
during this Parliament we've had one
Tory prime minister who turned out to be
a proven liar a second Tory prime
minister who was outlasted by a lettuce
after this week's pathetic no-show by
the Prime Minister what one word would
he use to describe himself might it be
weak what's weak is the party opposite
being unable to stand up is being able
to stand up to the people who fund them
and stand behind hard-working families
in this country wish you soon next time
as Chancellor during the pandemic and
his supposed Mastery of economic issues
was and remains a key selling point of
his leadership and he doesn't seem to
enjoy all of that now being a target for
opposition parties whatever the truth of
the causes of both the cost of living
crisis and the mortgage rates increase
labor is unlikely to let up with its
attacks and as homeowners increasingly
fill the bite that may prove painful for
the PM